l' oms appelle à davantage de recherches
sur les micro plastiques
ces fragments de plastique tellement
petit qu'on ne voit pas à l'oeil nu mais
néanmoins qui peuvent entrer dans
l'organisme alors comment est
essentiellement par par les autres
boissons
lorsque les particules sont inférieurs à
150 millions m2 mm et bien elles peuvent
ces particules une fois ingérée
pénétrait dans l'organisme et là on se
pose la question des conséquences pour
la santé
faut-il s'inquiéter l'om s affirme que
pour l'instant les niveaux que l'on
repère dans les eaux ne sont pas
inquiétants néanmoins encore une fois
les recherches sont importantes à faire
d'abord parce qu'il ya des pays dans
lesquels les autres boissons ne sont pas
traités suffisamment ne serait-ce que
contre les contamination fécale
ça n'est évidemment pas le cas en france
et quand on traite les eaux contre ces
risques de contamination microbienne et
bien dans plus de 90% des cas les
particules sont éliminés complètement de
ses eaux potables donc il n'y a pas de
risques liées cette fois ci au micro
plastiques
néanmoins il faut également s'inquiéter
parce que eh bien pour l'instant les
méthodes de mesure de ces concentrations
au micro plastiques ne sont pas
standardisés et c'est le sens de l'appel
de l'organisation mondiale de la santé
standard disons les méthodes faisons
davantage de recherches pour éviter
qu'un jour si les niveaux se mettent à
monter et bien il y ait des conséquences
pour la santé que personne n'a prévu
et puis bien sûr continuons à lutter
contre eux les plastiques et la
dissémination des plastique dans les
océans